Okay, so welcome to video number 11. We're
now going to be looking at the second
indicator, leading indicator, within the
business arena. So before we move on to
the all-important consumer, we're going to
look at the brother, if you like, of the
ISM Manufacturing Report on Business,
which is,
the ISM Non-Manufacturing Report on
Business, or sometimes called the NMI.
Now, the Non-Manufacturing Report on
Business covers the service sector, which
makes up 80% of the U.S. economy, and the
manufacturing sector, which we looked at
in video 10, makes up 20% of the U.S.
economy.
We've already explained pretty much the
reasons why we place a little bit more
importance on the ISM Manufacturing Report
on Business over the Non-Manufacturing
Report on Business.
But that doesn't mean the NMI is not
important. The Non-Manufacturing Index is
actually very important, because services
clearly make up a large portion of U.S.
businesses.
So we have to look at the NMI in tandem
with its brother, if you like, the
Manufacturing Report on Business, the ISM.
So when you look at both of them together,
you're going to get a very, very clear
picture of the health and the outlook for
the U.S. economy, and therefore,
potentially, the global economy,
because the U.S. actually makes up a
significant proportion of that.
So remember, we're looking here at the
U.S., Europe, and China, but at the
moment, we're still in U.S. businesses
before we move on to the all-important
U.S. consumer.
So taking both of these leading indicators
together is going to help you with your
positioning in generating your trade ideas
in your portfolio for positioning your
direction,
whether you're going to be long, short, or
market-neutral.
And again, there is no rulebook, but you
need to generate these ideas and go
through the processes to make sure that
you have a very, very good idea of where
the world is likely to go,
whether that's up, down, or sideways.
And you're going to be long, short, or
market-neutral, depending on your U.S.
view, your Eurozone view, your China view,
and your overall global view.
And you're going to get regional
perspective as well.
So let's go over to the presentation.
Let's have a look at the non-manufacturing
index, the ISM services sector.
And remember, treat the ISM
non-manufacturing index in the same way as
you treated the ISM manufacturing report
on business.
Because the makeup might be slightly
different, but essentially the reading of
above and below 50, expansion and
contraction, and the qualitative
statements, we use it in pretty much
exactly the same way.
So we define the ISM non-manufacturing
index and define the ISM manufacturing
report on business in pretty much the same
way and deduce our positioning in the S&P
500 from a combination of the both.
So let's go over to the presentation, and
I'll see you at the end of this video with
a summary on the non-manufacturing index.
Okay, so we're going to move on to
services.
So the non-manufacturing index, the NMI,
it's 80% of the US economy.
You get two numbers a month.
You get a preliminary number around the
middle of the month, and at the end of the
month, you get a final number, which is
the official number.
So the prelim number gives you a guide as
to what's going to be reported at the end
of the month.
You treat it exactly the same way as the
ISM manufacturing number.
If it's above 50, it's growing.
If it's below 50, GDP contraction
predicted 12 months before.
But specifically, the makeup composition
of the index is slightly different.
So now we're looking at services.
What do we get?
Four areas, equally weighted.
Business activity, new orders, deliveries,
and inventories.
That's what it's looking like recently.
That's business activity.
And business activity and new orders are
considered leading indicators on the NMI
itself.
They're the most sensitive.
So shifts in business activity month to
month.
And shifts in new orders month to month.
Now don't forget, the NMI is not real
goods bought and sold.
So this is the second reason why we prefer
to use the manufacturing index over the
services.
Because services can just literally be a
contract between a legal professional and
an accountant.
It's not necessarily a real good bought
and sold, a real product.
So there can be a lot of noise around it,
but it still is incredibly predictive.
So that's 2008 to now.
Business activity, 97.
New orders since 97.
Deliveries since 08.
Inventories since 08.
You're going to get the spreadsheets.
Go back.
Change the charts.
Go back as far as you can.
Get practice just creating the charts from
the data.
And getting an appreciation of what this
thing does over business cycles.
You treat it in exactly the same way as
the ISM.
But it's just services.
Not real goods bought and sold.
Yeah.
So 80% of the US economy predicts GDP with
12-month time lag.
85% certainty on its short history.
And it also tells us what to expect from
policy makers.
You also get the qualitative statement.
And you do it exactly the same way.
You get all of the industries in order
reporting the most growth or the fastest
growth to reporting the slowest growth.
Treat it exactly the same way.
And you take trading ideas from it.
Why is it important?
Predicting GDP.
Obvious.
Predicting stock market returns.
Predicting the business trends in a
particular industry.
Not so obvious.
But you can read between the lines.
Try to translate into trading language
what the guys are actually saying in the
report.
Same as the ISM.
But you also use it in tandem with the ISM
manufacturing index as a head check.
What you're going to see is they both move
in the same direction.
But in different business cycles, services
might move first.
Manufacturing might move first.
And they'll follow each other.
So what happens if the ISM is reported
above 50 for four years in a row?
And then the non-manufacturing index the
same.
But then the NMI goes below 50 for the
first time.
You're getting an idea of what's happening
in the economy at any one time by looking
at both.
What it's telling you is that the economy
is creaking and could be on the verge of
contraction.
In that situation.
And vice versa in the opposite situation.
If the ISM manufacturing index was
reported below 50 for a year in a row.
For 12 months in a row and contraction,
the rate of contraction slows for the
first time in a year in the
non-manufacturing index.
You're going to get a very quick idea of
what's happening in the world.
And for the ISM non-manufacturing index,
you can use the previous spreadsheet
called the ISM historical data master
summary.
You can fill that out in the same way
using the ISM non-manufacturing index.
And what it will spit out is a result
which tell you what's going to happen.
So go through that exercise.
If you go through that exercise, it will
be good for you because you'll learn how
the spreadsheet works.
Which means you'll learn the parameters
and the decision-making process of what
the result actually says and what you do
in your portfolio.
Okay, welcome back.
So let's try and summarize what we saw in
the presentation there for the
non-manufacturing index.
Well, the conclusion really with the
services sector is that we're treating it
pretty much exactly the same way as we do
with the manufacturing sector,
the ISM manufacturing report on business.
Except now we're just in the services
sector.
The makeup is a little bit different, but
it's not materially different.
The ISM services sector, the index, is
broken down into very similar sub-indices
to the ISM manufacturing report on
business.
And we pretty much treat them exactly the
same way.
Now, what you need to take away from this
really within the PMIs and within US
businesses is that you really need to
become a student of purchasing manager
indices.
Because once you become a student of PMIs,
what you're actually becoming a student of
is the biggest principle of all in
trading,
which is attempting to predict the future.
So what I want you to really do now, now
you've got to this stage, is to actually
go to those websites.
Go to the ISM website and download the
data.
You know, we've got the downloads for you
next to the videos, which is okay.
You know, that's a shortcut for you.
But really, you need to be going to these
websites yourself and downloading the data
and drawing your own charts
and correlating them with the S&P 500,
correlating them with GDP,
even going as far as correlating them with
earnings and, in particular, sectors and
stocks.
So, you know, that's taking things to the
next level.
Well, what I'm showing you here is really
the introduction to the thought processes
and the indicators that are really
important.
Now you've got to go away and teach
yourself.
You've got to become a student of PMIs,
not just in the United States,
but also in the UK, Europe, in Asia.
Once you become a student of the PMIs,
you're becoming a student of the biggest
principle of all,
which is predicting the future as a
professional trader,
deducing what the future is going to look
like by interpreting the numbers correctly
and then turning that interpretation into
real hard dollars.
So now we're going to move on to the
all-important consumer.
The consumer is important because the U.S.
consumer makes up over two-thirds of the
U.S. economy,
consumer spending, that is.
So what we do is we use PMIs, the ISM, and
the non-manufacturing index,
in conjunction with the most important
consumer sentiment indicator in the world,
which is the University of Michigan
Consumer Sentiment Index.
So let's move on to the next video, and
I'll see you in the introduction in the
next video
on the University Consumer Sentiment
Index.